that is aurelian's soul aurelian soul
has recently been reworked and recently
irelian Soul has been completely [__]
broken
all right if you love glitches bugs and
all things broken then make sure you're
subscribed to the channel because as
long as these things keep happening in
games we'll keep talking about them
cheers so aurelian Soul was first
released in League of Legends back in
2016 and for most of his six year long
history he's been fine he was a pretty
Niche mid lane Mage who stood out with
his orbiting stars for damage his
roaming potential and his Comet of
Legend ability which could grow his star
surge AOE stun to ridiculous sizes Maple
coming in the shooting star is there the
team will follow that means the
Inhibitors down but the grand show it's
just for the little bit that is one way
to Brute Force an inhibitor let me tell
you he was never really seen in Pro play
much except as a pocket pick for who he
and fans of the LCS will remember this
as a common occurrence whenever he
played aurelian Soul so Bjergsen is
complaining about the same bug and it's
apparently a visual bug of aurelian
souls passive so he said he was going to
play through it if it happens again they
were going to pause again and so to
speak it has happened again so we were
paused again and they're currently
working on a solution those who stuck
with him in solo queue found a fair
amount of success especially initially
after his release but his popularity
across all ranks started low and just
got lower over the years and so in April
2022 Wright announced he was a target
for the slew of champion reworks they
had planned although there were some
asole Mains that were scared of Riot
[__] him up others were cautiously
optimistic that this was a good thing
even the most die-hard fans could admit
that his janky kit could do with a bit
of a spruce that was also the fact that
the law described irelian's Soul as a
space God as old as the universe and
bigger than a mountain who creates
literal stars and Riot felt that
epicness wasn't really reflected in game
after teasing some of the rework
throughout 2022 Riot released the new
aurelian Soul at the start of February
this year and the announcement video
alone looked pretty sick true power is
only found possible
his new queue is now a continuous breath
of Starfire that can last as long as he
has Mana his improved astral flight
allows him to use his abilities midair
his e Singularity creates a black hole
that drags enemies to its Center that
damages them and executes them if
they're low Health while his alt brings
down a literal star from the heavens
but as you can probably tell from the
start of this video things haven't
really gone to plan he's been pretty
[__] bugged the first bug is on his
black hole ability Singularity it's
supposed to deal magic damage four times
a second to enemies within it but some
players have found the damage continues
even once they've left the black hole
and as vandral showed in a recent video
the real kicker here is that it doesn't
seem to end it just goes on and on if it
happens to you you just die slowly
I'm dying what is that
and this has also been shared on the
league subreddit by other players who
also find themselves dying slowly to
aurelian Seoul for seemingly no reason
but there is actually a reason here and
it involves another champion altogether
mordekaiser now if you aren't familiar
with Maude he's famously the most
historically buggy champion in League of
Legends so it's not too surprising that
he's the culprit hit hextech lab seems
to be the one who figured out that if
you're in an aurelian Souls Black Hole
as it expires while he is being altered
by Maud you keep taking damage for about
a thousand seconds that's over 16
minutes so yeah you're not gonna Live to
Tell the tale this was demonstrated in
another of vandral's Clips you can see
here aurelian's Soul has been altered by
MAUD and even after he dies Maude's
teammates continue to take damage like
some sort of plague but the bugs don't
end there hextec lab showcased how if
viego possesses aurelian Souls form and
uses astral flight just before all the
form expires he can spam viego's Q on
zero cooldown Twitter user horwald
discovered that using aurelian Soul
Singularity and then using his old
outside of its range allows you to just
Spam his alt forever even if it was
originally off cooldown only limited by
Mana oh yeah and vandro also discovered
that trying to use astral flight on
certain walls stops the player from
being able to use that ability again for
the rest of the game it's just
permanently locked from then on now Riot
did Issue a hotfix last week for
aurelian Seoul but it appears to be
purely enough to curb his then 52 win
rate but two days after that hotfix was
released Riot disabled aurelian sold
from the game now usually when that kind
of thing happens it's because a champion
has a major game breaking book or in
this case maybe a few of them Mount
aurelian Seoul appears to have been
enabled again for now but some of the
clips I've shown you in this video
happened just a few days ago so it looks
like maybe not everything has been
addressed in fact just yesterday a
vandral uploaded a video showing
aurelian Souls W seemingly setting off
an enemy jinn's traps in a bug that
looks like it could be related to that
abilities issue with walls I spent a bit
of time this week scrolling through the
irelian soul main subreddit just to get
a feel for what they think of this
rework and generally speaking it looks
like people are a fan of it this
aurelian soul looks like a real 2023
League of Legends champion he's flashy
fun to play cool to watch I just think
it would be a whole lot better once all
these crazy bugs get ironed out
I used to hate it when who he would pick
aurelian soul in pro games because you
just knew there was like a one in two
chance that the whole game was gonna
break so we end up with these like 10 15
minute pauses in the middle of pro games
just because who he loves playing a
rally in the soul